[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
sì è vero gioco in casa è
però diciamo il il mio ruolo stasera è
quello di provare a raccontarvi una
storia una storia che deriva dalle mie
esperienze io faccio il ricercatore e
mi occupo essenzialmente di numeri e
passò gran parte del mio tempo a
lavorare coi numeri e per questo che ho
deciso che stasera insieme a voi
cercheremo di dare i numeri come si dice
cominciamo dal primo numero
2050 perché 2050 perché 2050 è l'anno
della cosiddetta neutralità climatica
noi dovremmo riuscire per quell'anno a
rendere ad annullare il nostro impatto
sull'ambiente sul clima un obiettivo
molto ambizioso che non so se riusciremo
a raggiungere miley è lì che ci guarda
come se fosse il nostro diciamo target
finale
secondo numero 9 miliardi e 735 milioni
è la popolazione del nostro pianeta
prevista per il 2050
oggi siamo
7,8 milioni di persone quindi in 30 anni
avremo 2 miliardi di abitanti in più su
questo pianeta e saranno quasi tutti
concentrati in asia e in africa
terzo numero
726 milioni sono le persone che oggi
soffrono la fame
sono circa una persona su dieci e sono
anch'esse concentrate quasi
esclusivamente in africa e in asia
quarto numero
980 milioni
980 milioni sono invece le persone che
soffrono di obesità come vedete sono più
di quelle che soffrono la fame e noi
sappiamo che l'obesità deriva dalle
diete squilibrate
troppe calorie troppi grassi troppi
zuccheri ma anche da una vita che è
diventata molto più sedentaria quinto
numero
4.700 dollari contro 44 mila dollari il
primo è il reddito medio pro capite nei
paesi poveri
il secondo è quello dei paesi ricchi
anche qui un rapporto da 1 a 10 circa ed
è lo stesso rapporto che avevamo negli
anni 70 quindi 50 anni le disuguaglianze
di reddito sono rimaste le stesse
sesto numero
4 miliardi e 700 mila ettari contro 3
miliardi e 700 mila ettari la prima è la
superficie utilizzata
ad uso agricolo la seconda invece è la
superficie forestale
per lungo tempo
la prima è cresciuta a scapito della
seconda oggi questo è
avviene ma viene ad un ritmo molto più
ridotto perché perché è sempre più
difficile mettere a coltura nuove terre
e anche perché le terre già cultura sono
fortemente degradate circa un terzo
delle terre coltivate sono degradate e
questo significa che è molto più
difficile fare agricoltura in queste
zone
settimo numero 70 per cento è la
percentuale dell'acqua potabile
utilizzata in agricoltura in certe zone
può raggiungere anche la 80 o il 90 per
cento
anche qui quindi abbiamo molto poco
margine per crescere nell'utilizzo
dell'acqua quello che invece possiamo
fare è rendere più efficiente l'uso
dell'acqua perché le reti idriche
quasi ovunque nel mondo sono
anno del dei problemi molto forti e
spesso ci provocano grandissime perdite
ultimo numero
48 miliardi e 900 milioni di tonnellate
queste sono le emissioni globali di gas
serra cui l'agricoltura contribuisce per
circa il 15 per cento
emissioni che vengono in modo diciamo
prevalente dalle produzioni di origine
animale
otto numeri vi ho detto e in questi otto
numeri è racchiusa la sfida più
importante che abbiamo davanti in questo
secolo noi dobbiamo
riuscire a produrre cibo sufficiente per
10 miliardi di persone dobbiamo farlo
riducendo drasticamente le
disuguaglianze
azzerando la fame
migliorando la dieta e dobbiamo farlo
praticamente con le stesse risorse
la stessa terra coltivata e la stessa
acqua per irrigare e dobbiamo farlo
riducendo il nostro impatto sul clima
quindi riducendo le nostre emissioni
una sfida veramente ardua
veramente ardua e difficile
la domanda è ci riusciremo riusciremo
come dice un po il titolo che ho provato
a dare a questo intervento a nutrire il
pianeta senza renderlo inospitale per i
nostri figli e per i nostri nipoti
questa è davvero un quesito
che che dovremo affrontare nei prossimi
anni
e il tema è possibile
quello che vorrei provare a dire oggi è
che c'è una strada per vincere questa
sfida ma una strada che richiede grandi
cambiamenti
e quello che provo a raccontarvi questo
è un po il mio mestiere e sono le
conclusioni cui siamo giunti in uno
studio quella nostra università ha
collaborato insieme alla fao che voi
sapete l'organizzazione delle nazioni
unite per l'agricoltura e
l'alimentazione
allora primo punto di partenza
obiettivi possibili al 2050 primo
obiettivo a ridurre drasticamente la
fame dal 10 per cento di oggi al 2 e
mezzo tre per cento che vuol dire non
azzerarla quindi non siamo soddisfatti
di questo obiettivo ma è sicuramente un
obiettivo più raggiungibile in questo
momento secondo obiettivo ridurre
drasticamente le emissioni ridurre in
modo molto forte nei paesi ricchi tra i
60 e 70 per cento ridurre molto meno nei
paesi poveri che hanno bisogno di
crescere e di produrre di più
anche qui non siamo allo zero ci andiamo
vicini ma ci vorrà ancora un pezzettino
di strada
questi sono gli obiettivi come si fa
cosa serve per raggiungere questi
obiettivi servono tante cose messe
insieme e servono tante cose anche
complicate e costose
primo punto serve piu cooperazione
cosa vuol dire più cooperazione vuol
dire un massiccio trasferimento di
risorse tra i paesi ricchi e paesi
poveri e necessario investire nei paesi
poveri ed è necessario investire
soprattutto in infrastrutture perché se
un contadino africano riesce per esempio
ad attrezzarsi per produrre
con l'irrigazione ha bisogno che l'acqua
raggiunge sui campi e se vuole vendere
quello che non gli serve più per il suo
sostentamento ha bisogno di raggiungere
il mercato la città dove vendere i suoi
prodotti oggi questo non è possibile
serve poi più equità
e più equità vuol dire un complesso mix
di
strumenti che servono a ridurre le
disuguaglianze di reddito bisogna
investire moltissimo in sanità in
istruzione e anche in accesso all'acqua
potabile in particolare nei paesi poveri
dove questi diritti che per noi sono
scontati non sono assolutamente per
tutti
poi bisogna investire in tecnologie
adeguate a questi paesi sia in
agricoltura sia nell'industria
alimentare perché ci deve essere un
contributo forte che viene dai paesi
poveri per raggiungere gli obiettivi di
cui abbiamo parlato prima
poi cosa serve servono serve che noi
ci alimentiamo in modo più salutare e
più sostenibile cosa vuol dire qui avete
un confronto tra la dieta dei paesi
ricchi la dieta dei paesi poveri in
prospettiva noi dobbiamo consumare di
meno
dobbiamo consumare anche meno proteine
animali non annullarle non azzerarle è
questo è
una soluzione estrema ma però dobbiamo
ridurre sicuramente mentre da noi è
necessario consumare
più frutta e verdura perché sono fonte
di vitamine e di sali minerali molto
importanti per la nostra salute nei
paesi eri e poveri invece tutto deve
crescere e guardate crescere non vuol
dire raggiungere il nostro livello
perché se anche cresceranno i consumi di
prodotti di origine animale per esempio
continueranno ad essere poco più della
metà di quella che siamo abituati a
consumare noi quindi non ci sarà un
riequilibrio totale ma c'è un
adeguamento della dieta a un modello più
sostenibile più più ai anche più
salutare
poi serve ridurre enormemente gli
sprechi gli sprechi alimentari sono
molto difficili da misurare
qui avete una misura che oggi è stata
anche rimesso in discussione
cioè secondo i dati che vi sto facendo
vedere lo spreco alimentare circa poco
più del 10 per cento di quello che
produciamo e
oggi le stime ultime arrivano anche al
16 17 per cento è veramente difficile
misurarlo però quello che sappiamo che
dobbiamo fare è che dobbiamo sia nella
fase di consumo come quella che
interessa noi come famiglie sia nella
fase di produzione che interessa invece
le aziende dobbiamo ridurlo a meno del 2
per cento altrimenti gli obiettivi che
ci siamo dati non sono raggiungibili
poi serve tantissima innovazione
tecnologica in particolare in
agricoltura
e questo non vuol dire tornare
all'agricoltura dei nostri nonni quella
purtroppo non era in grado anche se era
probabilmente un'agricoltura più
compatibile con l'ambiente non era in
grado di produrre il cibo per tutti
dobbiamo però introdurre le innovazioni
che la tecnologia ci sta mettendo a
disposizione dobbiamo per esempio
smetterla di usare l'acqua
sprecandone una quota elevatissima ma
dobbiamo farci dire dalle piante quando
hanno bisogno di acqua e attraverso un
sensore distribuire l'acqua solo ed
esclusivamente quando serve dobbiamo per
esempio smetterla di lavorare i terreni
in modo profondo perché è lavorare i
terreni modo profondo significa incidere
sulla fertilità e dobbiamo invece per
esempio tenerli inerbiti lungo anche
durante l'inverno quando noi non siamo
abituati a vederli inerbiti perché
perché questo conserva la fertilità e
risparmia l'altro dobbiamo sicuramente a
ridurre drasticamente l'uso dei prodotti
chimici
anche se è molto improbabile che
riusciremo a farne a meno completamente
e poi serve
abituarsi all'idea che produrre cibo in
questo modo significa
avere costi più alti gli agricoltori
dovranno vedere remunerati i loro sforzi
e quindi dovremo abituarci ad avere
prezzi più alti peraltro
la crescita dei prezzi degli alimenti è
un fenomeno in corso da vent'anni e noi
ci aspettiamo che continui perché se
questi sono i
le premesse e se questa è la direzione
in cui vogliamo andare questo sarà
inevitabile
[Musica]
ovviamente tutto questo non non avviene
da solo serve che ci si mobiliti in
fondo questo è lo spirito di questa
serata e mobilitarsi cosa vuol dire
serve innanzitutto grande consapevolezza
da parte di noi consumatori alcune
alcuni sforzi in questa direzione gli
possiamo fare noi li possiamo fare noi
perché possiamo per esempio impegnarsi
per ridurre gli sprechi possiamo
impegnarci per cambiare il nostro modo
di alimentarsi questi sono alla nostra
portata e possono iniziare da subito poi
serve grande consapevolezza da parte
degli agricoltori che sono i
protagonisti di questo di questo sforzo
collettivo di questa meta che ci stiamo
dando tutti insieme e per questo motivo
secondo me li dobbiamo guardare con
grande benevolenza perché sono il
fondamento di questo sforzo
l'agricoltore ancora il mestiere più
diffuso al mondo
anche se da noi sono sempre di meno e
questo vuol dire che sarà soprattutto
nei paesi poveri che dagli agricoltori
vedrà il contributo fondamentale per
raggiungere questo obiettivo
infine serve un'azione politica molto
incisiva i comportamenti individuali
sono importantissimi ma senza una
politica lungimirante che affaccia
proprio questo che lo sforzo di questo
secolo non potremo raggiungere questo
obiettivo come cittadini credo abbiamo
il dovere di pretendere che la politica
sia all'altezza di queste sfide
non possiamo farne a meno
grazie
[Applauso]